(crowd hollering)
- [Ross] Boxwars really
feels like a medieval battle.
- [Crowd] Five, four.
- [Ross] The only difference
- [Crowd] Three, two.
- [Ross] is it's with cardboard.
- [Crowd] One, Boxwars!
(crowd hollering)
- [Ross] There's rules to
Boxwars, but they're very limited.
- You will die! (grunts)
- [Ross] There's no winners.
We like to say that if
you're in a Boxwars,
(screams)
you've already lost.
(growling)
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- I'm Ross, I'm one of the
supreme overlords of Boxwars.
Boxwars is a collective of
people that love to get together,
create cardboard creations,
and then destroy them in an epic battle.
It's more about competitiveness
in being creative.
The only materials that
you can use are cardboard,
adhesives like tape, hot glue.
Whatever you can find in packaging,
that's the stuff that we like
to use to build our suits.
Every single battle has a
new engineering challenge,
like building a giant aircraft carrier,
or building a monster
truck that actually rolls,
or a train, which has to carry in
a whole bunch of policemen.
We encourage people to
come down to our events
and build as elaborate costumes
as they can possibly make.
Once they've built the props,
then we all gather at a park,
and then, we battle.
Everyone comes in and clashes
and destroys everything.
(grunts)
Stuff that we've spent weeks on designing,
(wailing)
it's all gone in seconds.
(chill music)
We just started off
really small, but then, all
of a sudden, it blew up.
There's generally around about
50 to 100 people in the actual battle,
and then it can be hundreds
and hundreds of spectators.
We've got chapters that have started up
all around the world.
We've had groups in Japan, in Europe,
in America, in Canada.
It seems so childish,
but it's fantastic that
a concept like this
crosses cultural and language barriers.
Boxwars is based around comedy.
(laughter)
That's the whole point
of Boxwars, we're losers.
What we're doing is quite pathetic.
We should all have real jobs,
but here we are building
stuff out of cardboard.
If you laugh at us, that's
exactly what we want.
(growls)
Alright, that's pretty pathetic.
(laughter)